je n'ai aucune connaissance de tensions
particulières entre monsieur benalla et
d'autres personnes moi personnellement
je n'ai eu aucune friction aucune
tension dans mon service je pense que
vous avez audi auditionné le général
bio-farina qu'a pu vous vous dire qu'en
globalité il était satisfait de moi j'ai
été notés comme le sont les officiers
comme le sont tous les gendarmes
tous les ans j'ai une notation plus que
satisfaisante pas fait état de en ce qui
me concerne donc une friction
en ce qui concerne monsieur benalla je
sais pas je peux pas vous répondre mais
à mon avis non ça se passait plutôt bien
voire très bien